all right Charles is in Pensacola hey
Charles how are you hey Dave how are you
I deserve man how can I help
well first was thanks so much for rusty
I took it last year when she was with my
girlfriend when she was my girlfriend
and and I've been budgeting now and I
make less money than I have more of it
good you know here's what's going on so
I had a 25 of them in the Navy and I've
been budgeting so I have a bunch of
money in Legacy Fund right with my
emergency fund no you don't pay off
other people's debt until you're married
no you've already done this yes okay
ouch
all right so what's your question in
about a month you know when are you
getting married
I'm on the Navy and I'm training so with
me and training with her going law
school I don't know yet okay so your
questions says you're in training if
she's going to law school and you paid
off her student loans and the questions
what it was gonna be should I help her
with no board knowing that the answer
seems pretty obvious now you do not pay
other people's bills that you are not
married to once you're married then
you've combined your households in your
lives and your finances but until then
you don't because you have absolutely
zero protection plus it can negatively
affect your relationship she starts to
feel beholding to you beholding to you
and so forth and no you don't don't pay
other people's bills you know don't pay
your roommates bills don't pay your
fiance's bills don't pay other people's
debts off and in you know
with the promise or the hope that we're
going to get married if you want to do
all that that's fine but go ahead and
just go and get married it doesn't take
long to get married about 20 minutes and
you'll be married and so you know you
don't have to have and you have a
ceremony later you can do all kinds of
things you don't have to have you know
this major waiting period and all these
kinds of things if you've been engaged
for a while you've done some good
pre-marriage counseling lots of people
get married without having planned
everything out and it sounds like you
guys probably need to so what sounds
like to me